- Well, Tyler and I were just talking
about our kids and you've
got a daughter, right?
- I do. I have a-
- [Kelly] How old is she? Three?
- A three and a half year old girl.
Yeah. Her name is Jackson.
- [Kelly, Tyler and Audience] Aww!
- [Kelly] Oh my god, look at that picture!
[Tyler] Great age!
- [Parker] Yeah. We're
big Kelly Clarkson fans
in our household.
- Great taste
- I'm a little bit embarrassed to say that
I've spent too many mornings dancing
to your music with her.
- [Kelly] Oh my God!
- This morning was
'Stronger' we were dancing,
jamming out.
- I love that you do
that with your daughter.
- [Parker] Yeah.
- She's a daddy's girl
- Oh my goodness, yeah.
She's like can I come with you?
I'm like sorry sweetheart, not on this one
but I told her I would
ask a question for her.
- Okay (whispers) next
time you should bring her.
- I would love to.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Yeah, her question is what is
your favorite color?
- Oh, my favorite color is green.
- Green? Okay. Her is gold sparkle.
- Gold sparkle? Oh my God.
That's so cute. There's a cute book she
might like. Channing
Tatum actually wrote it,
it's called Sparkella.
- [Parker] Okay.
- My kids love it. Anyway, he was on here
promoting it and now
I read it every night.
Thanks, Channing.
- He wrote it?
- Yeah, he wrote it. He has a little girl.